I never answered.
I'd just delete the emails.
I just thought that the senders and I had nothing in common.
They didn't understand me,
and I didn't understand them.
Then one day, one of my colleagues in the parliament said
that I should save the hate mails.
"When something happens to you, it will give the police a lead."
(Laughter)
I noticed that she said, "When something happens" and not "if."
Sometimes hateful letters were also sent to my home address.
The more I became involved in public debate,
the more hate mail and threats I received.
After a while, I got a secret address
and I had to take extra precautions to protect my family.
Then in 2010, a Nazi began to harass me.
It was a man who had attacked Muslim women on the street.
Over time, it became much worse.
I was at the zoo with my children, and the phone was ringing constantly.
It was the Nazi.
I had the impression that he was close.
We headed home.
When we got back,
my son asked, "Why does he hate you so much, Mom,
when he doesn't even know you?"
"Some people are just stupid," I said.
And at the time, I actually thought that was a pretty clever answer.
And I suspect that that is the answer most of us would give.
The others --
they are stupid, brainwashed, ignorant.
We are the good guys and they are the bad guys, period.
Several weeks later I was at a friend's house,
and I was very upset and angry about all the hate and racism I had met.
It was he who suggested that I should call them up
and visit them.
"They will kill me," I said.
"They would never attack a member of the Danish Parliament," he said.
"And anyway, if they killed you, you would become a martyr."
(Laughter)
"So it's pure win-win situation for you."
His advice was so unexpected,
when I got home,
I turned on my computer
and opened the folder where I had saved all the hate mail.
There were literally hundreds of them.
Emails that started with words like "terrorist,"
"raghead,"
"rat," "whore."
I decided to contact the one who had sent me the most.
His name was Ingolf.
I decided to contact him just once so I could say at least I had tried.
To my surprise and shock,
he answered the phone.
I blurted out, "Hello, my name is Özlem. You have sent me so many hate mails.
You don't know me, I don't know you.
I was wondering if I could come around and we can drink a coffee together
and talk about it?"
(Laughter)
There was silence on the line.
And then he said,
"I have to ask my wife."
(Laughter)
What?
The racist has a wife?
(Laughter)
A couple of days later, we met at his house.
I will never forget when he opened his front door
and reached out to shake my hand.
I felt so disappointed.
(Laughter)
because he looked nothing like I'd imagined.
I had expected a horrible person --
dirty, messy house.
It was not.
His house smelled of coffee
which was served from a coffee set identical to the one my parents used.
I ended up staying for two and a half hours.
And we had so many things in common.
Even our prejudices were alike.
(Laughter)
Ingolf told me that when he waits for the bus
and the bus stops 10 meters away from him,
it was because the driver was a "raghead."
I recognized that feeling.
When I was young
and I waited for the bus
and it stopped 10 meters away from me,
I was sure that the driver was a racist.
When I got home,
I was very ambivalent about my experience.
On the one hand, I really liked Ingolf.
He was easy and pleasant to talk to,
but on the other hand,
I couldn't stand the idea of having so much in common
with someone who had such clearly racist views.
Gradually,
and painfully,
I came to realize
that I had been just as judgmental of those who had sent me hate mails
as they had been of me.
This was the beginning of what I call #dialoguecoffee.
Basically, I sit down for coffee
with people who have said the most terrible things to me
to try to understand why they hate people like me
when they don't even know me.
I have been doing this the last eight years.
The vast majority of people I approach agree to meet me.
Most of them are men,
but I have also met women.
I have made it a rule to always meet them in their house
to convey from the outset that I trust them.
I always bring food because when we eat together,
it is easier to find what we have in common
and make peace together.
Along the way, I have learned some valuable lessons.
The people who sent hate mails are workers,
husbands, wives,
parents like you and me.
I'm not saying that their behavior is acceptable,
but I have learned to distance myself from the hateful views
without distancing myself from the person who's expressing those views.
And I have discovered
that the people I visit are just as afraid of people they don't know
as I was afraid of them before I started inviting myself for coffee.
During these meetings, a specific theme keeps coming up.
It shows up regardless whether I'm talking to a humanist or a racist,
a man, a woman,
a Muslim or an atheist.
They all seem to think
that other people are to blame for the hate
and for the generalization of groups.
They all believe that other people have to stop demonizing.
They point at politicians, the media, their neighbor
or the bus driver who stops 10 meters away.
But when I asked, "What about you?
What can you do?",
the reply is usually,
"What can I do?
I have no influence.
I have no power."
I know that feeling.
For a large part of my life,
I also thought that I didn't have any power or influence --
even when I was a member of the Danish parliament.
But today I know the reality is different.
We all have power and influence where we are,
so we must never,
never underestimate our own potential.
The #dialoguecoffee meetings have taught me
that people of all political convictions can be caught demonizing
the others with different views.
I know what I'm talking about.
As a young child, I hated different population groups.
And at the time, my religious views were very extreme.
But my friendship with Turks, with Danes, with Jews and with racists
has vaccinated me against my own prejudices.
I grew up in a working-class family,
and on my journey I have met many people who have insisted on speaking to me.
They have changed my views.
They have formed me as a democratic citizen and a bridge builder.
If you want to prevent hate and violence,
we have to talk to as many people as possible
for as long as possible
while being as open as possible.
That can only be achieved through debate,
critical conversation
and insisting on dialogue that doesn't demonize people.
I'm going to ask you a question.
I invite you to think about it when you get home and in the coming days,
but you have to be honest with yourself.
It should be easy, no one else will know it.
The question is this ...
who do you demonize?
Do you think supporters of American President Trump are deplorables?